labour are electing a new leader this
could be their big chance to reunite the
party divided parties don't win
elections we build their reputation with
voters failed to convince many of our
remain unli voters fight finally and we
start their battle this is an
opportunity for labour we've got to
seize it so we ask the public to tell us
what makes the perfect labour leader
well well I thought the perfect Weibull
leader until they went the wrong way was
totally Tony Tony Blair let's see which
of the hopefuls fits the bill the number
one quality voters want is the ability
to listen jeremy corbyn's brexit policy
was seen by many as confusing for many
voters someone who wants to be Prime
Minister but won't answer whether they
bat leave or remain is perhaps a bit of
a joke he sat on the fence for years
before backing a second referendum
frustrating a lot of leave backing
labour voters what people around here
devote to leave really and I should be
getting what no one in from politicians
and
Leeson Andy is the only candidate not in
mr corbyn's current shadow cabinet and
she's long called for the referendum
result to be respected I could support a
deal I would support a deal voters also
want a Labour leader who's in touch with
ordinary people somebody
more in tune with what the current
situation what people are actually like
what eyes are like Jeremy Corbyn is a
London MP and his top team was full of
even more Londoners ever is far from
Lisa Nandi and Rebecca LAN Bailey our
northerners it's really cool it's and
it's north so I am cheerful this morning
which could help their case third on the
list is exactly what Bill Clinton's team
said about elections it's the economy
stupid as far as it goes with the money
much monetary they start to make a
forest we all win critics say labour has
an image problem when it comes to money
some of it goes back to the 2008
financial crash with Tories claiming
labour crash the economy and the last
wave of manifesto was full of pricey
crisis free broadband anyone so the new
leader is gonna have to convince voters
they can be trusted with our cash almost
a third of the public said they want to
change from Corbin ISM the current
leader was popular with members but led
the party to their worst election result
in nearly 100 years you know you really
really are looking potentially at a
conservative lands like he pulled his
party to the left some of his policies
were really popular but as a political
project it failed
Rebecca long Bailey doesn't really make
the cut here she gave mr corbyn's
leadership a rating of 10 out of 10 I
wouldn't give anything away anyway you
gave him rating well is and has been
accused of being Corbin's continuity
candidate from our research only 1 in 20
people thought it was a priority to have
a female leader I think
it's time for a woman to be the leader
of labor labor have never had a woman in
charge the Conservatives have had two
and both have been Prime Minister's many
in the party think a female leader is
long overdue but the public don't really
care so kiss Dharma can breathe easy and
strange though it might seem some say he
just looks right but if you were to
merge a load of male representations of
what a political leader looks like the
result would be Kia stahma finally the
public were asked about anti-semitism
Jeremy Corbyn was dogged for years by
the claim that he wasn't tough enough on
those accused of anti-semitism we need
someone who in the face of adversity can
definitely stand up in you know in the
eyes of the media in the eyes of the
population and truly pour actual
strength to their words but despite a
huge amount of media coverage it's only
a priority for one in seven people so
there we have it the perfect labour
leader according to the public we'll
find out if the successful candidate
comes anywhere close on the 4th of April